[Musique]
bravo public du 101 c'est malheureux le
sang est plus petit alors il y en a
beaucoup qui nous attendent devant la
porte on devra leur installer des
téléviseurs à une autre fois merci à
tous ceux qui sont venus alors Jean tout
de suite directement la vie politique
française actuellement et pleine de
bruit et de fureur faut pas oublier que
nous sommes maintenant à une semaine des
premiers tours des municipales c'est
normal alors tout le monde est affolé
monsieur Bart tente de ramener un petit
peu de discipline à Paris monsieur
Mitterrand un petit peu de discipline à
Toulon en favora ils sont vraiment au
bord de l'épuisement et on en profite
d'ailleurs pour commencer à envoyer
quelques calomnies et quelques
méchancetés je voudrais si je voudrais
le signaler parce que je trouve que
c'est pas bien et que cette campagne a
été très bien tenue jusqu'à maintenant
par exemple le préfet de police a
signalé monsieur Poniatowski et nous
allons le voir sur une coupure c'est
match qui a rapporté cette information
match de cette semaine tu vois la
campagne des municipales attirent lui
a-t-il dit dans la capitale trop
d'individus douteux extrêmement
désagréable c'est pas gentil pour ceux
qui viennent de l'extérieur
est venu quand même de Deauville
monsieur Chirac de Corrèze moi je serai
dans l'anneau et Chirac je me demande si
je ferais pas un procès en diffamation
parce que c'est à la limite de la
bienséance et de la courtoisie
elles vont un peu le débat il veut bien
est-ce que les candidats sont tous prêts
maintenant les candidats les candidats
sont prêts et je voudrais que nous
voyons le candidat type j'ai demandé à
barbe-rousse de faire un dessin du
portrait robot si vous voulez du
candidat des municipal et vous allez
voir bah bon c'est un garçon merveilleux
qui dessine comment on le sait avec
beaucoup de talents il fait en plus
Raphaël très vite car il nous a apporté
les dessins tout à l'heure sur le
plateau il les a fait cette nuit voilà
le candidat quand il a commencé les
municipales tu vois il y a un chien dans
le coin ce qui est normal parce que dans
les dessins de Barberousse il y a
toujours un animal il est content son
chien il voit son maître qui attaque et
municipal ça se passait ça il y a 15
jours candidat heureux candidat heureux
alors on va voir le candidat évolué et
c'est le deuxième dessin voilà le
candidat au bout de 15 jours de campagne
alors il a complètement transformé tu
vois leur le chien affolé de le voir
dans cet état-là il a grossi il est
devenu il est gonflé il est monstrueux
il est affreux alors pour savoir voilà
ce qui s'est passé à l'intérieur de cet
individu nous allons passer le candidat
au rayon X et nous allons voir et nous
allons voir que tout un tas de choses en
effet ce sont passées vous voyez il a
quand on le voit dans le Marais
dans cet état-là alors tu vois nous
voyons le on va le découvrir très
lentement mais on commence déjà un petit
peu à le voir il a le cerveau énorme il
a la tête qui est gonflé parce que il a
la tête pleine de sondages il a l’œil un
strabisme divergent très très fort parce
que à force de faire un tour d'horizon
politique et de regarder à gauche et à
droite ce qui se passe ça lui a mis les
yeux dans cet état là il est narines qui
palpitent parce qu'il faut prendre le
vent sans arrêt il a l'estomac plein de
vin d'honneur il s'est tellement il
s'est fait de petits blancs et de petits
rouges au zinc avec ses électeurs on
voit le mollet par exemple qui est très
développé tu vois le mollet à force de
monter les escaliers pour aller voir les
concierges la main qui est venue énorme
à portée toutes les paluches des
commerçants de son quartier il a
l'oreille alors ça c'est très important
qui s'ouvre de temps en temps en bonne
nouvelle et qui se ferme aux autres et
il a surtout les pieds en éventail parce
que ici imagine que s'il est élu ça va
être la béatitude 1000 à la triple
républicaine nouée quand même parce
qu'il a l'inquiétude d'être battu et
voilà le candidat dans cet état là le
pauvre malheureux avec cette analyse
qu'on peut faire de ce candidat
actuellement Jean je crois quand même
qu'il faudrait dire à tous les candidats
qui nous écoutent et qui se
retrouveraient une certaine ressemblance
que toute ressemblance entre ce portrait
et même n'est que pure coïncidence
pas à nous écrire c'est pas vous non ce
qui m'ennuie gens dans tout ça cette
pensée qu'il va y avoir des battues bah
tu sais non parce que je crois qu'en
France la grande chance de la France et
qu'il n'y a jamais de battu dans les
élections et ça c'est merveilleux on
n'est pas aux États-Unis si tu verras
jamais monsieur un homme que Monsieur
Ford pleurer parce qu'il a été battu aux
élections il y a pas de battu en France
il y a un gagnant qui a gagné qui est
élu et puis il y a l'autre et l'autre
qui s'est battu et qui a travaillé pour
l'avenir qui lui donnera raison car on
ne fait pas taire tu le sais la voix de
la vérité en marche de la justice du
progrès social pour une France plus
juste et plus humaine voilà ce qu'il y a
en France il y a pas il y a pas il faut
tu vois chapeau c'est une belle phrase
est-ce que maintenant que les
candidatures sont sont déposées c'est
plus calme c'est un peu plus calme
puisque il y a eu un échange de lettres
tu le sais Monsieur Guichard et écris
monsieur bar monsieur bar a répondu à
Monsieur Guichard président de la
République a écrit monsieur bar qui
reçoit un courrier énorme monsieur
Chirac avait écrit monsieur bar monsieur
barbe a répondu monsieur Chirac ce
marché avec Monsieur Mitterrand qui a
répondu à Monsieur marché et c'est ça
qui est tout à fait étonnant d'ailleurs
c'est que il se voit toute la journée et
la nuit il s'écrit ça c'est une chose
qui me surprendra toujours
je n'arrive pas à comprendre pourquoi il
s'écrivent autant ces gens-là si se voit
toute la journée pourquoi il se parle
pas ah mais il se parle il se parle sans
arrêt tout le temps il se parle ah il se
parle mais il ne se croient pas et non
c'est ça le problème il ne se croit pas
parce qu'il se connaissent ce qui fait
qu'à nous ils nous font des promesses
verbales mais entre eux comme ils se
connaissent ils veulent des preuves
écrites c'est ça le drame écrite donc
ils n'ont pas de parole ils n'ont pas de
parole mais on leur pardonnera parce
qu'ils ont des lettres
[Musique]
digne de notre ami Patrick durgel voilà
un homme qui a un nom extrêmement connu
on l'entend sur la meilleure radio de
France on peut dire la meilleure radio
du monde dans la meilleure émission bien
que tu n'y sois plus je suis malheureux
il s'agissait ça s'appelle comment c'est
le rayon course
soit enfin l'antenne parce qu'on l'a
tellement entendu il était normal qu'on
commence un peu à le voir et depuis 4
ans que je travaille avec Patrick je
suis ravi de te voir ici tu sais c'est
un homme qui vous fait tous rire parce
qu'il prête sa voix bah si c'est vrai il
faut pas la faire ils prennent savoir à
combien de Voda combien vous avez fait
déjà environ 200 environ 200 le même
homme sans trucage sans rien en direct
fait tous les dimanches matin quelque
chose détenant on s'y croie par exemple
là tu vas nous faire qui aujourd'hui sur
ce plateau je vais faire 4 imitations
toutes les missions là je vais là-bas en
faire deux avec le même thème la
publicité parce que beaucoup de grandes
vedettes se sont mises à la publicité
madame Bardot a fait une publicité pour
des pantalons récemment alors j'ai pensé
que par exemple Johnny Hallyday pouvait
très bien garder les mérites d'une
lessive
s'il vous plaît musique
[Musique]
toutes les lessives sont les mêmes
quand il s'agit de laver ma blouse
je dois souvent laver ma blue
tâche de café ou bien de crème
il faut la laver chaque jour
oui je la lave autant que je l'aime
et je la laverai toujours
[Musique]
avoir
et je lavais chaque jour
les couleurs pas c'est sans espoir
ma blouse c'était mon seul amour
cette lessive extra c'est mauvais
si jamais utilisé bobo ma blouse aurait
gardé c'est ton chaud
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est terrible
comme ça la lessive qui jaunit c'était
bien et maintenant Claude Nougaro
maintenant
ce sont les ce sont les produits
voilà alors musique
qu'ils sont bien mes produits qui sont
bien
parfois lorsque ma faim se ranime
[Musique]
j'ai toujours là de sous ma main
cassoulet confie ou terrine
ou bien saucisse de Toulouse de Toulouse
tous mes produits sont bien naturels
vous laissez
sans colon
ils viennent de mon pays de cocagne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour eux même pas m'aimer va à la
castagne
oh mes produits
[Applaudissements]
faire ça en direct comme ça de plein
pied formidable c'est un sacré bonhomme
non seulement il leur prête sa voix mais
il leur prête des textes drôles c'est un
mec terrible
aurait pu faire une belle phrase comme
celle que tu vas nous dire tout de suite
j'ai bien aimé parce qu'elle est c'est
une très très jolie phrase et telle que
telle que le président Edgar fort c'est
les faire il a dit vaut-il mieux pour un
homme politique être un joueur de bridge
ou un joueur de poker et à l'argent ton
avis toi là dessus bah je ne sais pas
moi j'ai inclinerai je dirais plutôt
pour le poker ah oui mais alors là tu
passes pour ta paroi non pas
spécialement c'est bon ce que j'aime
bien le poker que tu aimes bien aussi
d'ailleurs je te ferai remarquer mais
c'est parce que je crois très vrai j'ai
beaucoup joué au poker et je sais que
pour un homme politique le poker c'est
très important j'ai l'impression que
plutôt que de les envoyer à l'ENA on
serait mieux de leur apprendre le poker
parce que d'abord ça leur apprendrait
tout de suite à sa nombre de choses très
rapidement ils apprendraient autour du
tapis vert d'une table de jeu ça
répondrait que les tapis vert pas mal de
conférence c'est exactement la même
chose il serait par exemple au poker
comme en politique il ne faut bluffer
que gagnant il serait qu'au poker comme
un politique la relance et comment
l'économie la relance doit être toujours
immédiate il serait également qu'au
poker comme on élection rien n'est
jamais gagné et rien n'est jamais perdu
avant la dernière donne au poker comment
politique n'avoir peur de personne mais
craindre tout le monde exactement au
poker comme en politique avoir des nerfs
d'acier gagner sans triomphalisme et
perdre avec le sourire voilà ce qu'on
devrait là et on devrait leur apprendre
ça parce que ça les aiderait énormément
mais tu sais oui non je voudrais savoir
quand même que tu me donnes ton
sentiment au fond oui toi qu'est-ce que
tu trouves qui est le plus le moins
dangereux en politique le poker ou le
bridge écoute je te dirai franchement
que pour un homme politique je crois que
c'est le poker est moins dangereux et
les hommes politiques qui ont choisi le
bridge je leur dirai s'il m'écoute
attention n'oubliez jamais qu'au bridge
quand on est vulnérable les chutes comme
double
en plus au poker il y a toujours au
bridge pardon oui c'est toujours un mort
il y a toujours un mort
les gens sont méchants et ben savoir moi
quelqu'un qui est bien vivant là-bas je
voudrais savoir de la part de Christine
Fabrega qui est auprès de son
téléscripteur quels sont les dernières
nouvelles de la matinée que le film
écoutez il vient de tomber une petite
nouvelle tout à fait extraordinaire et
qui vous allez voir d'une brûlante
d'actualité en effet vous n'avez pas été
sans remarquer que depuis l'ouverture de
la campagne électorale les murs de nos
villes sont surchargés d'affiche dont la
superposition fait étrangement penser à
un mille-feuille chaque partie bien
entendu se faisant un malin plaisir de
recouvrir les affiches des autres et
bien figurez-vous qu'une société vient
d'inventer une colle miracle qui est
allée sur le recto du laffiche fera
décoller automatiquement et dans les 10
minutes qui suivent la deuxième affiche
qu'à partir adverse aura eu l'impudence
devenir posé sur la première abrite
c'est ingénieux ça chouette oui mais
c'est pas le tout de vouloir poser des
affiches encore faut-il qu'elles
tiennent debout au propre et aux figuré
et que évidemment elle projette des
arguments propres à lécher les lectorat
et bien je vous conseille de regarder
très attentivement ce qui va suivre car
si un jour vous avez l'intention de vous
présenter aux élections je vous assure
que ça peut vous servir
[Applaudissements]
ça va bien salut je vous amène le texte
définitif de mon
afficheur
c'est le seul qualificatif qui convient
aux candidats Maurice frigo qu'un comité
d'individus
pour gérer les affaires de la commune
c'est bon
je sais bien c'est un team formidable
seulement en période électorale tous les
coups sont fermés voilà donc alors je
l'accuse de près de fabrication de
trafic d'influence d'abus de biens
sociaux etc etc
et je termine comme ceci et bien non les
électeurs
sont borisent frigo que notre belle
Berry n'est pas faite pour les canards
c'est excellent c'est bon hein alors ça
nous fait deux fois canaille une fois en
haut et une fois en bas de l'affiche
alors je vous ai imprimerai chez deux
Canaries en robure allongé un demi gras
36 12 ça tire l’œil formidable merci
merci
votre canaille m'appelle faites donc un
patron vous me direz ce qu'il raconte
sur moi sur son affiche il y a quelqu'un
ah ben voilà comment ça va patron
je vous apporte le mon texte pour mon
affiche élector qu'est-ce qu'il y a
quoi
ratiose ah bon je vous apporte je vous
apporte montagne
c'est quelque chose
36-12 ça tire l’œil c'est embêtant ça il
faut que je trouve autre chose
vous n'avez pas une idée ou un il me
faudrait un mot court énergique mais
ayant de la classe comme canaille moi
j'aimais bien
le mieux hein consulter
le dictionnaire électoral d'accord
allez-y
alors ouais
pull vaut rien malfaiteur coquin filou
canard voilà canaille ça sonne bien
riche
imposteur fripouille ravisque scélérat
composerai en Europe capital gras
40 12 c'est voyant ah bon très bien édit
à part ça qu'est-ce qui dit de moi le
Joseph sur son avis à part canaille il
vous traite de Prévert escrocs de trafic
en influence le beau grand il sait y
faire parce que c'est excellent ça c'est
excellent ah si je comprends bien faut
que je refasse complètement mon affiche
maintenant puisqu'on est obligé de
mettre scélérat mais ton scélérat alors
scélérat il n'y a pas d'autres mots pour
définir le candidat rati qui est l'autre
prudence de se présenter à vos suffrages
non c'est petit c'est mièvre c'est
minable pour moi après avoir abandonné
ses enfants l'Assistance publique il se
riche en défenseur de la famille
maintenant alors les enfants et même pas
marié certes mais ces arguments
influenceront la clientèle
de brutalité excessive sur la personne
de son épouse il a l'un des sens de
brider les voies des électrices en se
qualifiant de protecteur de la femme au
foyer à cette énergumène vous ne
répondrez qu'une phrase à la porte
scélérat
à la porte canaille ça voulait dire
quelque chose
en Europe capital 42
ensuite il s'attaque à votre vie privée
ah j'aurais dû y penser ça j'ai pas fait
abandonné vos enfants c'est une très
bonne idée votre femme et il termine par
à la porte scélérat oh là là oui alors
avec une affiche pareil il va être élu
au premier tour ça vous croyait mais
évidemment plus aucune femme votre a
pour moi maintenant
ah Joseph tu es là toi comment tu vas ça
m'a fait plaisir de te voir
parce que tu sois le parrain de notre
petit dernier
ton canaille très bien venu pour c'est
les rats émerveilleux
préfère la fiche de l'autre c'est ça
changer les mais comment ça
il suffit de modifier la signature
monsieur frigo vous signez l'affiche de
Monsieur Raty et Monsieur rati la fille
de Monsieur frigo
[Musique]
s'il y a un deuxième tour alors
qu'est-ce que vous ferez ah ben ça c'est
facile celui de nous deux qui sera le
moins bien placé donnera ses voiles à
l'autre et la raison le plus important
c'est de battre le concurrent du parti
adverse alors moi je vais vous proposer
un texte pour l'affiche là non non
citoyenne citoyen pour assainir enfin la
gestion de notre belle commune je vous
demande de reporter massivement vos voix
sur mon ami d'enfance alors je la
mettrai les frigo rapide enfin
premier tour et on termine par oui voter
tous pour cet homme intègre à qui je
suis fier pour ma part de serrer la main
signera-t-il ça me fait plaisir bravo
très bien et maintenant que le meilleur
gagne
à bientôt c'est les rats adieu canaille
de prendre un verre
vraiment plaisir à ta femme ben tu sais
elle en voulait pas d'autre oui ma femme
[Musique]
sans gentils en province quand même
politique
de beurre que j'ai acheté hier chez mon
épiciers j'ai payé 4 francs 30 ce qui
met donc le beurre comme partout
d'ailleurs toutes les boutiques de
France à peu près entre 17 et 18 francs
kilos ça doit varier très peu et tu sais
que la commission des marchés communs a
refusé la vente à l'URSS de 75000 tonnes
de beurre à un prix de un peu inférieur
à 5 francs je crois que c'est quatre
francs 50
kg 75000 tonnes de beurre à 85000 tonnes
mais pourquoi on attend de beurre bah tu
c'est parce qu'on a trop de vache c'est
ça a l'air assez simple comme ça et en
fait ça ne l'est pas tellement parce que
ça date pas d'aujourd'hui la la le côté
beurre on a trop de beurre cette espèce
de voilà c'est à toi d'aujourd'hui ça
date d'une dizaine d'années le ministre
de l'Agriculture de l'époque c'est de
s'apercevant déjà qu'il y avait trop de
beurre à réuni son état-major des
énarques tous des grosses têtes qui sont
arrivés comme ça il leur a dit pourquoi
a-t-on tant de beurre alors ils sont
bien réfléchir c'est quand il
réfléchissent c'est ils font pas ça les
choses à moitié et il y a un moment il y
en a un qui a dit d'où vient le beurre
une pas bête comme tu vois comme
question alors ils ont pris un
dictionnaire parce qu'ils ont un
dictionnaire dans le ministère ils ont
regardé le beurre vient de la crème à
partir de là ils ont remonté toute la
filière la crème le lait le lait la
vache et ils sont dit s'il y a trop de
beurre c'est qu'il y a trop de vaches tu
vois toujours très légère et c'est à ce
moment-là que on a proposé à chaque
paysan français une prime d'abattage par
vache laitière abattue pour arriver à
épuiser le stock de bœuf c'est pas ça
plus tard le ministre de l'Agriculture
le même ministre non pas le même on
faisait pareil c'est aperçu que le prix
du veau avait monté dans les proportions
inquiétantes alors il a réuni son
état-majorque sont arrivés des énarques
avec des grosses têtes il leur a dit
pourquoi le voit-il autant augmenté il y
en a un qui a dit monsieur le ministre
c'est parce que on a abattu les vaches
laitières ministre a dit quel rapport
mais
les vaches laitières qui font les veaux
administrative
et ça a été tu vois et ça date pas c'est
un problème qui est vieux comme le monde
j'en revenant au beurre quand vous
voulez vendre aux Russes là pourquoi les
Russes ils ont pas de vache si les
Russes ont des vaches mais alors le
problème des vacheries c'est très
particulier si tu veux c'est délire que
les Russes ont des vaches qui sont
planifiées c'est-à-dire qu'elles doivent
donner un contingent de lait dans
l'année alors c'est toujours pareil tu
as des vaches courageuses qui font ça en
5 6 mois et après le foot plus rien
pendant les autres mois tu vois c'est
déséquilibre un peu et puis tu as les
vaches qui voit qu'ils vont pas y
arriver plus elles vont plus elles
angoissent et une vache angoissée ça ne
donne plus de lait du tout alors ils
sont toujours à déséquilibre des
ressources plan là c'est vrai
explique-moi ce beurre bon marché qu'on
voulait vendre russe il est pas bon ce
beurre il est bon il est douillet Paris
que celui-là c'est le même fait je veux
dire pourquoi pourquoi nous le vend pas
à nous ce bar bon marché pourquoi on
nous le vend pas à nous mais c'est la
même chose parce que si on nous le vend
à nous à ce prix-là tu t'imagines bien
que A4 30 kg plus personne va acheter
celui qui coûte 16 francs donc le stock
va être des 75000 tonnes va diminuer
mais celui-là il va augmenter alors
c'est pareil
mais les Russes sont pas idiots vont pas
acheter du beurre au même prix que nous
à 18 francs kilos je m'en fous les
Russes alors tu pourras c'est ça
l'avantage et en plus de ça il faut pas
oublier que ça fait travailler le
commerce que ça fait travailler les
exportateurs et les exportateurs
l'exportateur qui était monsieur doumag
est forte embêter d'ailleurs que de
l'affaire se fasse pas il l'a dit dans
les journaux et il dit tu vois il a dit
on en fait tout un fromage il a même
fait de lui il a même ah il est drôle
c'est rigolo tu veux que je te dise sans
faire d'humour il faut peut-être aussi
que les exportateurs fassent leur beurre
tu vois il ne l'a pas fait de même
celui-là parce que je crois qu'il te l'a
laissé tu vois mais en dehors de ça il
faut pas oublier une chose non plus
c'est que pour exporter 75000 tonnes de
beurre dans le monde actuel il faut
fatalement graisser la pâte au
fonctionnel et progresser la pâte on va
pas leur reprocher de prendre un peu de
beurre au passage c'est normal se fait
partie de la vie politique courante
extraordinaire du beurre aux petits
suisses
les petits suisses à qui l'on a demandé
ce qu'il pensait du mariage
[Musique]
comment se passe le mariage dans le jour
du mariage
il décide à l'avance puis vivre un peu
ensemble puis quand le jour de leur
mariage ils achètent leur robe quoi
c'est les parents qui achètent la robe à
la fille puis les parents au mari Ben
ils achètent un habit après il se marie
vont dans l'église et il y a la femme
mais tu veux prendre cet homme paribout
et si elle dit oui alors
[Applaudissements]
ils sortent et puis des fois il y a des
gens ou avec des ballons avec des fleurs
puis on leur lance du riz dessus et
l'après-midi
des fois ils sont un peu gênés parce que
c'est la première fois comme ça alors
tu aimerais avoir des enfants plus tard
parce que pourquoi j'aime pas marier
toi non plus
cette décision pourquoi comme ça
jusqu'à quand on doit faire le ménage
tout
monsieur ne font jamais le ménage
j'aimerais avoir un mari qui aime faire
la cuisine et
plus chez les pommes de terre parce que
tu déteste ça est-ce que quelqu'un a
assisté
tu te souviens pas très bien euh non pas
très bien mais je sais que c'est pas
c'est pas Lausanne qui sont mariés c'est
dans un village moi je dis que c'est
impossible de souvenirs du mariage de
nos parents parce qu'on était même pas
né parce que d'abord on fait pas un
enfant afin d'être marié je trouve il
peut avoir des enfants sur se marier
mais il faut qu'il les adopte
Isabelle moi je trouve il peut parce que
il peut déjà c'est une année à l'avance
et puis des as donné la graine et puis
après il faut faire un ah et puis après
on se marie
tu penses que c'est tout à fait normal
comme ça moi j'aimerais avoir des
trentaines d'enfants
et tu penses que tu arriveras à suivre
ton travail
j'en mettrais je m'occuperai de l'autre
oui
ils ont
faim
et tu devrais avoir combien de garçons
et combien de filles sur ces 30
moitié garçon moitié fille 15 garçons et
15 filles alors bon courage Carole
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors là ça devient une tentative
maladroite qui a pour effet de diviser
les grands courants qui aspirent à la
démocratie à visage humain et s'il fait
plus de 10% au-dessus de 12% alors là ça
devient vraiment un grand courant c'est
un grand courant national qui agit avec
des moyens différents dans le sens même
du combat que nous menons depuis
toujours et dans les voies rallieront au
second tour je l'espère toutes les
actions de progrès de justice sociale
pour un changement véritable dans une
démocratie renforcée et c'est la raison
pour laquelle à l'heure actuelle on voit
tous les partis politiques qui viennent
autour des écologistes qui les caressent
qui leur font des câlins qui leur font
des choses très gentilles parce qu'ils
se rendent compte que 12% en deuxième
tour quand ça va se reporter ça va être
très intéressant c'est à dire une phrase
qui a eu monsieur Mitterrand cette
semaine qui a dit notre analyse
socialiste va être exactement dans le
sens du combat écologique tu vois on
vient on vient on les caresses
importants
municipales est-ce que tu connais un
patelin qui s'appelle Pouilly un patelin
pardon un village pardonnez-moi puis
sous charlieu oui
pas moi où j'étais conseiller municipal
tu as été conseiller
tu sais ce qui s'est passé
la seule commune de France ou un fils se
présente sur une liste de gauche contre
sa maman qui est sur l'autre liste c'est
un drame cette rencontre de ce que
Corneille aurait pu faire avec ça un
fils qui lui cru ma mère qui lui dit tu
te rends compte ça aurait été très très
beau
c'est pareil mais je crois que les
journaux auraient pu faire quelque chose
je m'étonne qu'ils aient pas sauté sur
cette information les journalistes vous
savez les journaux qui font des titres
des gros titres à sensations il y avait
des froides fantastique à faire je ne
sais pas moi par exemple je vois bien en
première page un mai une un fils veut
être mère à la place de la sienne ça
c'est un titre c'est quand même mais
genre tu m'as dit qu'il se présentait
sur une liste de gauche alors moi je te
propose voilà il bat sa mère et il
reçoit les félicitations de Mitterrand
ça ça c'est encore plus formidable ça
c'est encore plus extraordinaire encore
une nouvelle politique
tu sais que le Président de la
République a reçu cette semaine à
l'Élysée Bastia et Fourou maintenant ça
c'est pas une nouvelle politique ça
c'est c'est
quoi à ton avis pourquoi il a reçu
spécialement Bastia et fourrou qui sont
deux spécialistes de la mêlée parce que
l'un est dans Bastia et que l'autre met
le ballon à l'intérieur parce que à
l'heure actuelle le président de la
République c'est bien que la mêlée
politique est beaucoup plus violente
encore que de la été hier après-midi la
mêlée de France Écosse je voudrais dire
que les coups que se donnent les
candidats à côté les coups de soleil
hier c'était de la rigolade et le
président de la République est tout de
même l'arbitre de la situation et en
tant qu'arbitre il a peu de moyens parce
que emmêlés politiques il y a pas de
règle on peut faire ce qu'on veut mais
les politiques en introduit le ballon
quand on veut on pousse mais avant
l'introduction on se relève on peut même
plaquer les adversaires elle a dit non
l'arbitrage doit pas être facile hein il
est très difficile le président n'a
aucun moyen il peut pas siffler coup
franc il peut pas siffler hors-jeu il
n'a peut-être peut-être qu'une solution
il peut renvoyer les deux équipes au
vestiaires ça il peut le faire alors là
je comprends pas ça tu peux pas parler
clairement pour tout le monde dans une
employée des symboles tu veux dire par
là envoyer c'est-à-dire dissoudre
l'Assemblée et provoquer de nouvelles
élections anticipées je parle pas par
symbole quand je dis renvoyer le
renvoyer les équipes au vestiaires c'est
mes vestiaires élections c'est le même
mot qu'est-ce qu'on dit dans les député
quand elle était battu
un dès qu'il a pris une veste c'est le
même mot il y a pas de différence
je vais aller retrouver comment
s'appelle Madame Rose parce que je suis
sûr qu'elle aussi a été enthousiasmée
par la victoire de la France sur
l'Écosse en rugby qui ne l'a pas été
moi il y a rien à faire c'est la
politique qui m'intéresse le plus même
que c'est très étonnant pour une femme
et avec les événements de ce mois de
mars j'arrête pas d'y penser mais merci
beaucoup au revoir monsieur Régnier au
revoir
quelle semaine il y en a eu du sport ah
ça on peut dire que pour le sport on a
été gâté hein oh oui ça ça nous on a été
gâté vous savez vous costaud comme vous
êtes enfin belle femme comme vous êtes
là je vous vois très bien dans la mêlée
moi
j'avais raison si mon mari me retenait
pas je me jetterai dans la mêlée et
pourtant je vous assure que ça doit être
dangereux hein les coups de pied en
vachent en dessous on sait bien que ça y
va il y a des hommes qu'on voit traîner
dans la boue ça sans les risques du
métier c'est comme ceux qui
malheureusement quand la mêlée n'est pas
franche en fin de compte c'est toujours
les parties qui en prennent un coup et
ça fait mal ça et dites-moi vous avez vu
le petit joufflu là sur la droite il a
fait une sacrée montée ah oui oui c'est
vrai même qu'ils ont dû être fiers de
lui à Deauville
en tout cas il a fait plaisir avec sa
remonté au grand arbitre il s'en moque
l'arbitre il est tous à l'arbitre c'est
l'arbitre pas tout à fait vous savez les
Auvergnats non l'arbitre il était pas
auvergnat il était même pas français
dans ce match là mais de quoi vous me
parlez vous Madame Rose
rugby alors
le quiproquo est énorme parce que
finalement le rugby et la politique
c'est du pareil au même c'est du sport
même que sauf qu'en politique comme le
disait monsieur Amar Amadou tous les
couches ont permis la attention l'aile
gauche joue contre l'aile droite
en rugby je m'y connais aussi vu que mon
mari il est baisé et je peux vous dire
que Monsieur Chirac pour un corrézien
c'est étonnant il joue pas finement
parce que quand il a le ballon ils
veulent garder il veut monter à laisser
tout seul ça va pas bien dans sa tête
alors logiquement monsieur d'Ornano qui
est comme qui dirait le capitaine de
l'aile droite quand il attrape le ballon
au bord vous pensez qu'il veut pas le
repasser à Chirac pas fou et ça
cafouille à droite
même que de faire il s'est fait plaquer
par son propre partenaire mais alors à
gauche en pilier ils ont marché
il est dangereux il impressionne le
public
en mêlé en pilier la contre le
grand-olivier Guichard dans les tribunes
ça fait craquer
et le petit jeu vert dans tout ça il
joue quoi il joue trois quarts Jobert
Jobert trois quarts chétif comme il est
il joue de mie
c'est vrai
il joue pour lui tout seul aussi là lui
quand il attrape le ballon plein il
trouve une touche voilà et j'ai ouvert
une touche il doit pas y être habitué le
pauvre petit
dites-moi comment trouvez-vous que joue
Mitterrand monsieur Mitterrand bon il
joue classique lui quand il a le ballon
il repasse un communiste qui passe à
radical de gauche qu'il passe un
communiste et bien obligé de le passer
la socialisme qui repasse à Georges SAR
qui passe à
rocards il faut encore le transformer
après mais attendez là je me fais pas je
me fais aucun souci j'ai bientôt parce
qu'au milieu du terrain au centre il y a
Monsieur Edgar fort lui on le voit pas
il joue pas les vedettes mais il se
déplace rapidement et je vous assure
connaissez soit marqué par l'aile droite
et par l'algorge Edgar Faure lui il
loupera pas la transformation c'est
toujours lui qui transforme bravo
je vous embrasse
comme vous le savez le week-end dernier
ce sont déroulés en Norvège les
championnats du monde de biathlon et
guipiero notre reporter de charme a eu
la chance a eu la chance d'assister à
une épreuve spéciale
qui était composé bien entendu de ce qui
de fond et de tir à la carabine mais qui
va réjouir les écologistes ennemis de la
chasse car comme vous l'avez voir on y
tue absolument pas d'animaux ici
en Norvège ou se déroule cette année les
championnats du monde de biathlon
aujourd'hui nous assistons à la seconde
manche de l'épreuve d'endurance sur 20
km entrecoupés de tirs à la carabine
notre compatriote Émile schmolitovic a
congé une véritable surprise en prenant
la troisième place à l'issue de la
première manche de cette discipline le
favori le Finlandais Olaf le soir avec
ayant échoué lamentablement il nous est
permis d'espérer de venir champion du
monde de biathlon mais l'anticipons pas
Émile armes sont fusil vise
oui
et ratent il l'a raté mais je vous
rappelle que chaque concurrent a droit à
trois essais rien n'est perdu attention
deuxième essai encore raté mon de nos
chances de devenir champion du monde de
biathlon c'est ce temps au fur et à
mesure attention 3e essai oui il l'a eu
quelle précision bravo il a eu son
skieur bravo émiche molinovic grâce à
vous nous devons champion du monde de
biathlon pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de France Merci Émile
cheminée merci merci
c'est une bonne idée ça une bonne idée
et l'auteur est sur le plateau notre ami
Bernard Régnier là et bravo nana
je suis contente de vous retrouver parce
qu'on a soif d'entendre des vedettes
alors là on va s'offrir Eddy Mitchell
quoi je vais continuer mon petit
panorama publicitaire Eddy Mitchell lui
va nous vanter les mérites d'un
dentifrice toujours la publicité ça
m'intéresse beaucoup alors un bon moyen
de communication
[Musique]
j'avais des crises de hockey et ma
dentition qui s'écaillait c'était la
photo dentifrice
c'était la faute dentifrice
[Musique]
avec du seul lien vie active
de dentifrice
[Musique]
je viens vers toi tu m'attends dans ta
blouse blanche
[Musique]
lapin salam tu as retrouvé cette immense
je crois bien que je fais regretter
d'avoir pris cette batte au rabais que
sonnerie de dentifrice
si j'avais utilisé moins loin le
dentifrice du rockeur ça ne se serait
pas passé comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Patrick maintenant est-ce qu'on pourrait
avoir droit un peu à Aznavour oh mais
avec plaisir Charles Aznavour lui il a
eu des problèmes avec un mobilier qu'il
ne trouvait pas adéquat vu ses faibles
dimensions c'est un peu le Jobert de la
chanson Charles Aznavour et alors il a
décidé d'en fabriquer un lui-même enfin
il va vous raconter lui-même musique
c'est mes aventures voilà musique
Aznavour
[Musique]
j'ai décidé de changer quoi tout mon
vieux
mobilier et j'ai opté pour des trucs
dans le vent dans le vent tout est en
vert en acier
polyester salut bosser oui tout le monde
[Musique]
pas le problème
sauf lasse quoi que mon lit oui est trop
bas aïe aïe aïe et que le canapé du
salon et plus haut que moi plus haut que
toi alors quand je veux m'installer
et
ne parler plus de me
mollet mon bureau m'arrive
quant à mon requin cher une balance pas
du tout et ma nouvelle salle à manger à
table est tellement grande qu'on ne peut
plus y entrer la prochaine fois que
j'aurai
ma maison je choisirai de meilleurs
dimensions
où je me ferai Vald un mobilier un matin
j'en ai
marre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
assez dur de casser derrière on a perdu
du mal maintenant il a un talent il
devrait pas faire de la radio mais de la
télé Patrick tout le temps il va le
reprendre
un sondage politique
cette fois-ci un sondage un véritable
sondage qui a été fait par un journal
italien qui a demandé à ses lectrices et
elles étaient forts nombreuses mesdames
avec quel homme célèbre aimeriez-vous
comment je pourrais dire attends
aimeriez-vous faire un gros câlin
nocturne
et les réponses ont été tout à fait
surprenantes en effet les Italiens ont
mis en numéro 1 à très peu de choses
près et là c'est tout à fait normal nous
ne dirons rien Robert Redford Paul
Newman et Alain Delon en numéro 6 Enrico
Berlinguer le secrétaire général du
Parti communiste italien en numéro 9
monsieur Jimmy Carter le président des
États-Unis et en numéro 13 seulement
monsieur Giscard d'Estaing le président
de la République française alors là je
suis quoi le 13 ça porte bonheur
parce que je trouve que c'est vraiment
ahurissant ce résultat est à hurissant
non maintenant c'est vrai je veux dire
Jimmy Carter bon on le connaît Jimmy
Carter est on veut je voudrais voir la
photo de Carter on va la passer tu vois
derrière sa cuisine tiens regarde il
faut pas qu'il ressemble à Berto un
peu quelque chose avec les cheveux un
peu plus grises les cheveux seulement
poivre c'est exactement Berto donc il
est très mignon Carter
mais ça tout ça n'est quand même rien il
faut le dire il faut être sincère à côté
du de l'extraordinaire charme à côté du
pouvoir étonnant de séduction de
Monsieur Valéry Giscard d'Estaing je
vous
réponds-nous jusqu'à tout de même là
quand même une seconde regarde ah ça n'a
pas de moi pour moi ça pour moi je veux
dire si j'étais femme mais on est
peut-être assez mal placé toi et moi
pour juger de ces choses alors je
voudrais qu'on fasse alors je voudrais
qu'on fasse et qu'on montre bien que les
femmes italiennes n'ont pas le goût des
femmes françaises je voudrais qu'on
fasse un sondage sur la salle je
voudrais mesdames si vous aviez un gros
câlin uniquement les fins les hommes
vont vous taisez vous ne dites rien si
vous aviez un gros câlin nocturne à
faire avec Monsieur Jimmy Carter je
voudrais savoir lesquels d'entre vous
seraient d'accord pour le faire avec
Jimmy Carter s'il vous plaît voulez-vous
à l'applaudit maître me le donner Jimmy
Carter allez-y
si vous aviez un gros câlin nocturne à
faire avec Monsieur Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing qui serait d'accord
et Ben et Ben et ben voilà et ben voilà
les femmes françaises sont des femmes de
goût et on se rend compte tout de suite
que si la classe politique française
n'est pas toujours extrêmement efficace
on a quand même les plus beaux et de
très loin
où tu mets par exemple Jobert dans tout
ça il est hors concours
et Michel Debré non classé il remonte
des profondeurs du classement mais il
espère fermer la prochaine fois
changeons de sujet un petit peu je sais
je sais que tu as vu tu as vu à la télé
malheureusement le match Saint-Étienne -
Liverpool
de Geoffroy-Guichard à Saint-Étienne je
l'ai vu là-bas parce qu'il faut aller
voir Saint-Étienne
uniquement pour ça j'y suis allé dans le
match il a été ce qu'il a été peu en
balance c'est vrai mais j'adore
l'ambiance de de l'ambiance
extraordinaire qui règne dans ce stade à
partir de 5 heures de l'après-midi il a
la voix qui donne éjecter au milieu d'un
groupe de supporters stéphanois qui
était vraiment comme ils le sont
c'est-à-dire le bonnet l'écharpe le
coussin aux armes Saint-Etienne tout ça
en vert les drapeaux les banderoles et
qui ont fait un raffut pendant à partir
moi je suis arrivé une heure avant le
match à peu près tu vois ils m'ont mis
la tête mais comme un chaudron il m'a
braillé dans les oreilles tous les
champs de guerre et Dieu sait qu'ils en
avant sans arrêt et à côté de moi juste
vraiment comme les Christine là tu vois
coller à côté de moi j'avais un monsieur
d'une 35 ans à peu près très calme très
froid pas un mot et je me suis dit enfin
stéphanois calme parce qu'il y en avait
pas énormément ce soir là à
Saint-Étienne et il s'est fait son petit
sandwich à un moment donné il l'a mangé
il a pas dit un mot et quand les équipes
sont rentrées sur le terrain vraiment 5
secondes avant le coup d'envoi avant que
l'arbitre ne siffle il a sorti de sa
poche une écharpe rouge et il a fait
Gohan Liverpool
et il a plus dit un mot ça a été
extraordinaire et l'ambiance surtout
l'ambiance je veux dire tu sais que
quand quand revéli Patrick a attiré le
Gaulle arrêté la la gare était là-bas
alors ça a été oui comment mais
qu'est-ce que c'est mais qu'est-ce qu'on
nous fait pourquoi il a pas marqué et
quand l'anglais a tiré sur la barre mon
anglais à côté de fait simplement
c'est tout ça c'est la classe ça c'est
la classe c'est le flegme je pense qu'il
faudrait que les Français la même classe
ce que je voudrais le 16 mars pour le
match retour quant Saint-Étienne va
aller à Liverpool je voudrais que nous
ayons nous supporter français dire
qu'ils soutenance Saint-Étienne c'est
normal parce qu'on les aime bien ils
représentent la France dans cette
aventure de Coupe d'Europe mais je
voudrais que nous les soutenions avec
autant de classes autant de flegs autant
de autant je dirais d'élégance qu'on a
eu que cet anglais en avait ce soir là
au stade de Saint-Étienne je voudrais
que je sais pas comment dire mais ce
serait presque
allez les verts allez les verts
simplement
si on chante à mon avis il faut un
accessoire mais faut pas faut pas qu'on
tombe dans le déguisement il faut qu'on
ait quelque chose d'extrêmement alors
j'ai acheté un peu de matériel là-bas tu
vois tu as les foulards les foulards de
Saint-Étienne
alors on se met simplement autour du cou
voilà comme ça on se met autour du cou
comme ça et on essaye à nouveau pour
voir ce que ça va donner ah allez les
vrais ça c'est mieux allez les verts il
faut peut-être un peu plus d'accessoire
allez allons-y tous ensemble allez
allez allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]